it's very easy that's nothing to friend
to call our friend joe walsh of
flip-flops yeah that's very easy i'm
just not just putting it out there yeah
but it's very hard what he did
it's not easy to say i've been a tea
party conservative my whole life hear me
out hear me out i've been a tea party
conservative my whole life still um okay
well that we can have a whole
conversation whether that even exists
anymore right but
he towed the company line i voted for
trump 2016
and then took him a little longer than
most americans or half of american to
realize yeah this guy really is a piece
of [ __ ]
um and then he shot himself in the foot
the leg and even probably even the
stomach at some point even in the brain
and said i can't do this anymore
but but there's nothing wrong with that
god what do you mean i don't know he's
got a glass of wine right now
you're saying that he's just had one too
many five-hour energy drinks listen to
what you're saying yeah he you're saying
that he should have no trump my guy
and just stick with you that's what
you're saying you should have done you
guys were all baptized by mainstream
media and confused
like people have eyes and people have
ears they don't hear what you're saying
oh really people have visited what he
said
when trump went up there and said yes i
stand with putin and the next day he had
a reverse course let's stay a lot of
people were discussing this about that
let's stay on that topic stay on that
topic right there
look at the economy today look four
years ago you're not looking for a
situation today
can i talk so wait a minute sure so
you're blaming covet for today's economy
are you also blaming russia are you also
blaming putin are you also known
if with the inflation if it's because of
covet which is your rhetoric and you
gotta you gotta blame that no problem
let's play that card then why were gas
prices 220 in december of 2020. they
were going up before buying or swimming
if you're going to blame biden for what
he spent on covid trump did the same
[ __ ] well we know he's a democrat no
no become a democrat and get it i'm not
going to vote no no no no no no no no no
no because you're because i'll also
blame biden for the [ __ ] that he's done
both can be [ __ ] up you can't it's
not a binary decision you cannot i can't
say trump's horrible i'm voting for
biden biden's wonderful vote like
both could be horrible presidents do you
take a quote can be bad you but but
that's that's a that's an emotional
statement which i'm not surprised
both of you guys are part of the
emotional community which i appreciate
this is why there's some people in your
life that can reason and that helps you
out but i think emotions is good yeah
you know i think it's a very
entertaining place to be yes i have a
heart guys but but you think but you're
the tin man but pre-date you set the bat
about 30 minutes ago you threw that bad
comment in there when we talked about
china okay you also used air quotes you
weren't watching
someone ate a bat so what i'm trying to
tell you is if you play that card okay
and florida shut down for two weeks the
rest of the country florida shut down
longer than two weeks whatever the
timeline was but everybody's coming here
i lived in florida the whole [ __ ]
time we shut down like two months every
no you lived in dallas as well you lived
in texas as well
don't get it twisted you live in texas
for a minute it'll be down to a week
yeah yeah but but here's the point go
back to it day before covet
mm-hmm go a day before covered february
4th how's america doing
financially you know to foreign
isis afghanistan china north korea iran
palestine this israel how's america
doing day before kovit policy
policy-wise i
showed you already emotional we were at
each other's throats but you're because
there's part of that where people why
each other no no no no why though but
multiple things going on the economy
could be going well for most people yeah
but people could also have there's an
underdog people hating do you realize
do you realize
how scary it is
for you like a pelosi
to have had control
of congress for god knows how many years
they don't look up at presidents they
look down at presidents and they're
they're part
of the same thing
i don't disagree yeah so if you're going
to call out once again are you going to
let me make my point
it's okay you're screaming i like it so
let me tell you where i'm at here with
this
if if we know congress looks down at
presidents they don't look up at
presidents they don't say oh my gosh
he's a president behind the president
behind behind closed doors like this
he's got no influence as much as you
guys think he's got him he's nobody
let's just frickin make him feel good on
his ego he's going to leave we're going
to keep controlling the policies and we
keep playing our games and we have the
card so we're invited to the same
parties we'll you know keep using this
to do insider training make our money go
big buy the big houses just let this
guy's ego go we'll go do our own thing
right no problem okay then all of a
sudden a guy shows up
and this guy calls out all your [ __ ]
non-stop
this guy says swamp this guy says all of
this stuff
next thing you know
people are asking questions that you
have not been asked for a while
do you think
congressmen should be able to invest
after having insider training i'm sorry
miss pelosi did your husband ever make
any financial decisions after having
insider no we've never done that no boom
that video goes viral congratulations
that was today
but even during that time is when it
started that star that calling out
started during that era it started then
when i was in china then a guy shows up
and starts asking those questions and
exposes it to america and americans are
sitting there saying
damn if that's true and then they said
hey guys we got to freaking create a
confusion asap get people protesting get
people riding let's shut down the
economy let's do all this stuff now we
got monkey pox it's horrible oh my gosh
we're gonna die let's let's use fear
fear fear fear fear the american person
who are emotional they fell for it and
guess what we are in the state of
affairs that we are in today so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]